people of the internet retrorecords who
are here and now we are taking a deep
dive in the brand new hogwarts legacy
playstation exclusive haunted hogsmeade
shop quest that is right it is exclusive
to playstation for one year we are going
to deep dive now break down the full
trailer so we're watching it with
captions here they're gonna be some
interesting things that we're gonna find
there as well but let's dive in
okay so we get the first shot of
hogsmeade and the music again like i'm
just dude the music sets the tone so
well
and i love this night shot
and you get i mean is it is it snowing
or raining i think it's i think it's
like a light snow the music really sets
the mood right away sets the mood
okay and then we have this kind of
little fly-in view here
we've got the hogs head here so this is
like we've seen this kind of area before
hello and then we get this shot of
honeydukes we've got a student here
saying hello
madame mason so this name cassandra
mason was actually leaked a while back
on imdb this is something that we found
on the harry potter game subreddit a
long time ago cassandra mason and then
the other one was helen thistlewood many
are guessing that helen thistlewood will
be the herbology professor i think that
makes a lot of sense so now we finally
know that cassandra mason is actually a
real character as well so we start
zooming into a different area of
hogsmeade here we've got honeydukes and
what looks like these little like
pumpkins or something bouncing in the
window here let's go ahead and play it a
little bit more hello madame mason i
understand you have a shop to sell i
understand you have a shop to sell all
right so let's back this up a little bit
take a look at this wizard right here
okay so this must be cassandra mason
right here or which rather looks like
they've got the quill here writing
something down there's a lock on the
door remember we saw the locks on the on
the doors in the asmr videos and we
wondered what's going on with those
i think you will find my terms quite
generous i think you will find my terms
quite generous oh man okay and we've got
a lot here in this shot okay there's a
lot here we've got this right here says
no trolls we have this sort of
interesting symbol right here it's got a
line going and then somewhat of an x is
that three brooms or three wands
is this like the handle of a wand or is
that meant to be a broom
i'm not really sure and then we have a
hand here possibly a
hand of glory and then there's something
over here that says or and something
yeah we don't get a better look at it
though unfortunately
what's the catch okay now things start
to get crazy there's a treasure chest
right there and then these little dolls
or dummies whatever you want to call
them we saw these things in the autodesk
session so if you guys didn't watch the
autodesk trailer
that was a breakdown of some of the more
technical aspects of hogwarts legacy and
a lot of people just thought oh that's
probably just for their design of you
know helping them design the characters
that's kind of just like a model they
used but no they're actually here in the
game instead and they're gonna come to
life here in a second and kind of go
crazy a little bit uh but we have
something shining over here in the left
as well we got the chest right there in
the middle and then lots of spider webs
who knows though man there might be more
spiders in here too and then what is
this object over here on the right it's
got kind of a gold goldish look to it
let's see if we get any closer on any of
this
nope immediately cuts away you are wise
to be wary mason says we have a broom
over here on the left we have a portrait
here portrait here definitely a wizard
because they're holding a wand holding
the wand with their left hand and then
we're kind of zooming in on the chest
right here don't really uh interesting
little just looks like some kind of
floral pattern here
why is your mistress selling the shop
why is your mistress selling the shop
and whatever that chest that we were
just walking up to this is clearly the
same room
because we could see these kind of on
the right side so now they have opened
the chest and she looks very distressed
by what she has found in there your
mistress selling the shop
she has had rotten bad luck with
she has had rotten bad luck with the
last few tenants
penny new name new name so the person
talking now is someone named penny so we
have cassandra mason and now we have
someone called penny uh sounds like a
younger voice luck with the last few
tenants
my guess is that we will the way that we
will take ownership of the shop
we'll have to buy it but it will be
it'll be like really cheap because it's
haunted so mason's just trying to mata
mason's just trying to get out of there
my term's quite generous so they're
gonna give us a good deal because they
don't want any part of it students like
what's the catch so
mason is penny's mistress
so the character is asking penny why is
the mister selling the shop
and then this then they go all inception
on us i mean
walking down the hall and it just
completely shifts right there then this
wall just goes flying the other way
those who came before you fastidio
okay so we've got penny we've got fast
studio vestidio sounds like a
poltergeist he kind of does yeah i think
this is definitely more i mean the
haunted house right they're calling it a
haunted house they're going with that
haunted
vibe these mannequins coming to life
clearly there will be
i think you guys could be spot on with
like a poltergeist maybe a poltergeist
behind it maybe a
maybe it's a dark wizard i think it'd be
cooler though a poltergeist is a really
good idea i like that those who came
before you just could not seem just
could not seem to escape the darkness ah
so we gotta it's like something we're
gonna be trapped trying to get out of
here
will you oh my gosh that's so creepy
watch this shot right
there
dude okay and then looks like a
continuation of that scene our character
takes off running they're right behind
us
whoa look at the movement on that though
that was kind of a weird zombie movement
from that mannequin
watch it's like over here on the right
and then it just sort of almost like a
little teleport
not a teleport but a lunge and then who
is this oh dude there are spiders whoops
yep
yep those spider webs
uh we were warned man we were worn by
the spider webs okay is that a beard is
that a beard or is that long hair or
both i think it might be both a beard
and long hair is it fastidio is it
merlin is it slytherin because the other
trailer with sebastian that one focused
on slytherin then we get more spiders
there are a lot of arachnophobics out
there i feel for you because it seems
like this game is not shying away from
it
and then right in the middle of them we
saw protego there briefly
and then another uh dude that's an
awesome spell
watch your step watch your step
evil laughter oh man i love it let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments below as always thank you all
so much for watching i'll talk to you
again soon